ein neuer lockdown am abend beschlossen
am tag danach im bundestag debattiert
der sorgen nicht nur die maßnahmen
sondern auch die entscheidungswege für
kritik der krone ausnahmezustand wird
unübersichtlicher geschäfte geschlossen
friseure geöffnet kinder je nach
bundesland früher oder später dann doch
wieder in der schule nicht genug
impfstoff und dazu die gefährliche
mutation die kanzlerin warnt genau
deshalb zu mehr vorsicht aber können die
bürger nicht auch anders geschützt
werden und wie hilft man denen die am
meisten unter den einschränkungen leiden
politik gegen die pandemie welcher weg
ist der richtige
unser thema in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde ich begrüße sie ganz
herzlich willkommen aus berlin ich darf
meine gäste vorstellen
wolfgang kubicki ist bei uns er ist
bundestags-vizepräsident und
stellvertretende fdp-bundesvorsitzende
und seit 50 jahren mitglied in der
partei
man sieht dass mich an und ich begrüße
allerdings schön von der cdu
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
für bereiche familie senioren frauen und
jugend und digitale agenda zwei bereiche
die auch gefragt sind in dieser pandemie
und zugeschaltet ist uns petra köpping
von der spd sie ist staatsministerin im
freistaat sachsen für soziales und
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalts schönen
guten abend und ich begrüße york leuten
von der afg er ist einer von zwei
bundessprecher das sind die
parteivorsitzende der partei und der ist
mitglied im europäischen parlament im
guten abend erbeuten
er hat uns auch wunderbar herr kubicki
die kanzlerin hat heute gesagt ich
glaube nicht dass das hin und her einmal
öffnen einmal wieder schließen für die
menschen mehr berechenbarkeit bringt als
ein paar tage länger zu warten und sich
den überblick zu verschaffen dass man in
einem kontinuierlichen prozess wirklich
auch öffnen kann
also lieber längeren lockdown und dann
endlich richtig öffnen hat sie recht die
kanzlerin
das hört sich ein vordergründig sehr
plausibel an das bedauerliche daran ist
nur dass die kanzlerin genau wie wir
nicht wissen wie die weitere entwicklung
konkret aussehen wird wir haben ja eine
rechtliche grundlage und daran will ich
immer wieder erinnern die
verordnungsermächtigung für grundrechts
beeinträchtigung der länder fußen auf
dem infektionsschutzgesetz und wir haben
im november das infektionsschutzgesetz
im bundestag novelliert und erst an die
inzidenz zahlen gekoppelt an die zahlen
15 35 stehen im gesetz und daran müssen
sich auch alle freiheits und grundrechts
einschränkenden maßnahmen messen lassen
um es mal freundlich zu formulieren weil
incidents zahlen über 50 sind massive
grundrechtseingriffe erlaubt buy-ins
dienstag unter 35 über einen längeren
zeitraum an die gar keine mehr ist wie
eine kommunizierende röhren und deshalb
finde ich es vernünftig wenn die länder
wie schleswig-holstein
nordrhein-westfalen thüringen stufen
modelle entwickelt haben um zu erklären
welchen incidents zahlen über einen
zeitraum von sieben tagen beispielsweise
welche öffnungs maßnahmen zwingend
notwendig sind weil sie gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben sind
das ins belieben von ministerpräsident
und der bundeskanzlerin zu stellen ist
mit der rechts auch noch nicht in
übereinstimmung zu bringen aber die
ministerpräsidenten die kanzlerin haben
sich doch bei ihrer konferenz genau
darauf geeinigt dass sie gesagt haben 35
ist sozusagen das neue maß das finde ich
sehr interessant dass die
bundeskanzlerin sagt 35 das neue 50 weil
sie damit die maßnahmen die bei 15 noch
erlaubt wären nach dem gesetz ist auf
die ganze 35 herunter brechen will das
ist eben nicht erlaubt das ist
rechtswidrig und das ist ziemlich
offensichtlich wir uns gesetzt man
hinschaut wird das feststellen und ich
bin sicher dass die menschen die jetzt
noch im lokal bleiben müssen obwohl in
den ländern und den kreisen oder
gemeinden öffnungs schritte gemacht
werden müssen wenn sie den klageweg
beschreiten würden werden sie
feststellen die gerichte werden sich
genau darauf konzentrieren der
volksgerichtshof mein name ist vor einer
woche genau das erklärt er die kontakt
beschränkungen die ausgangs beschränkt
und baden württemberg deshalb aufgehoben
weil er erklärt bei einer effizienz von
etwas über 60 ist eine so gravierende
maßnahme nicht mehr gerechtfertigt und
daran bergen wie gesagt die gerichte
orientieren das ist keine willensbildung
die ministerpräsident machen können die
exekutive muss sich am gesetz genauso
wird hier wie den menschen auch und das
gesetz ist ziemlich eindeutig frau kopp
in sachsen trägt er die beschlüsse mit
aber ab montag sollen in sachsen die
schulen teilweise geöffnet da die
grundschule und die kitas wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe wie passt das
denn zusammen kann man das denn machen
in einer zeit wo die inzidenz hier noch
hoch sind naja das eine ist dass wir in
sachsen ja eine sehr lange strecke jetzt
hinter uns haben wo tatsächlich sehr
hohe incidents in sachsen gewesen sind
wenn ich an den november an den dezember
denke verlagen wir teilweise bei 460
bundesweite rekord und trauriger rekord
das muss man schon so sagen und sind
mittlerweile bei 75 pro 100000 einwohner
in sieben tagen angekommen
das ist die eine entwicklung die wir
durchgemacht haben das heißt aber eben
auch dass gerade unsere kinder in den
kindergärten und in den grundschulen
eine sehr lange zeit hinter sich haben
wo sie diese einrichtung nicht besuchen
konnten
und gestern in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin ist ja noch mal klar
gestellt werden dass eben die freigabe
für die länder besteht dass man durchaus
im schulbereich eigener festlegung
treffen kann was ihr andere bundesländer
im übrigen auch schon gemacht haben
wir sind da weder die ersten aber wir
haben gesagt nach so einer langen zeit
ist es eben auch wichtig was mit den
kindern in dieser zeit passiert aber
trotzdem war diese regelung haben ja
beinahe dna oder eine ergänzung zu herrn
kubicki
wenn das signal ist das was wir gesagt
haben wir haben wirklich viel geschafft
in den letzten monaten nochmal eine
instituts bei 74 das ist das eine und
das andere die verantwortung die wir
eben auch haben wir kinder die in diesem
bereich eine sehr lange zur zeit zu
hause gewesen sind und meine position in
sachsen die neunziger eben
sozialministerin gesundheitsministerin
und eben auch ministerin für
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt deswegen
ist neben der gesundheitlichen
betrachtung eben auch mit aufzugreifen
was bedeutet denn das für diejenigen die
die maßnahmen die den maßnahmen im
grunde genommen ausgesetzt sind wenn ich
noch einen satz sagen darf zu herrn
kubicki die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundeskanzlerin die haben gestern
festlegung getroffen ob und beschließen
und der die verordnung erlassen das
machen die bundesländer und ich komme
gerade aus dem landtag heute und hat mit
drei ausschüssen darüber beraten und hab
gesagt wie können wir unsere verordnung
aufbauen das heißt ja mitwirkungsrecht
die haben ein anhörungsrecht übrigens
auch die städte gemeinden und
landkreisen und erst morgen am morgigen
tag wollen wir die neue verordnung dann
im kabinett beschließen
ok frau schön wäre wenn wir jetzt um
diese intelligenz von 35 reden kubicki
seit 35 ist die neue 50 also die wir
haben uns jetzt alle daran gewöhnt
dachten immer wenn wir 50 erreichen dann
haben wir richtig was geschafft jetzt
sollen 35 erreichen
jetzt sagt sachsen wir haben 74 und
öffnen aber trotzdem die schulen wie
soll man das bürgern noch klar machen
dass das eine konsistente strategie
naja erstmal bin ich ja froh dass herr
kubicki und auch die fdp mittlerweile
anerkannt hat dass 35 auch im
infektionsschutzgesetz stehen es waren
mich gestern und auch heute teilweise im
bundestag immer die rede von seiten der
fdp dass die 35 eine völlig beliebig
gegriffene zahl ist und das ist falsch
die steht im infektionsschutzgesetz und
in dieser grenze können auch noch oder
müssen auch noch maßnahmen gemacht
werden und was dort auch zu entsteht ist
das wenn neue ereignisse dazu kommen die
man vorher nicht vorhergesehen hat in
diesem fall einen mutation dass man dann
auch entsprechend reagieren kann und
reagieren muss und von daher finde ich
total richtig dass man sagt wir müssen
verschiedene
schütte einziehen und die 35 dient vor
allem dazu dass wir die infektionsrate
so weit runter bekommen dass wir auch
mit einer mutation die wir ja im land
haben nicht noch mal so ein
exponentielles wachstum haben dass wir
nach wenigen tagen woche im kloster man
konsequent sein und so ist so machen wie
dieser initiative noko fit und dann
sagen da müssen wir ganz runter dann ist
doch diese 35 auch wieder in die zahl
ist die dann auf einmal sagt man dann 35
nicht jetzt machen wir 10
naja am ende ist das ein
abwägungsprozess und die ministerin hat
ja auch gesagt es sind natürlich auch
soziale themen die eine rolle spielen
und die der grundsatz in meinen augen
muss sein so weit runter wie möglich und
dann zahlte öffnungs schritte und da
müssen die schulen da müssen die kinder
dann müssten die familien an erster
stelle sein und genau das wird ja auch
gemacht ich hätte ja auch ein
einheitliches vorgehen gewünscht über
alle bereiche hinweg und hoffe dass die
länder in den nächsten wochen noch da
hinkommen dass man wirklich so ein
perspektiven plan macht und dann auch
gemeinsam festlegt was öffnen wir den
wannen ab welcher inzidenz erneuten wie
sehr oder wie gut halten sie den den
effekt der durch den locker und jetzt
gekommen ist würden sie sagen das ist
eine richtige maßnahme gewesen weil die
infektionszahlen er wirklich jetzt auch
stark runter gegangen sind
wir haben im gesetz den
verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsatz und ich
will gar nicht in abrede stellt das
durch den lockdown eine geeignetheit
mancher maßnahmen da ist die frage ist
aber sind sie erforderlich und
angemessen in dieser schärfe das in der
abwägung von rechtsgütern
unverhältnismäßig heißt den nutzen der
maßnahme müssen die kosten überschreiten
und mittlerweile wird vielen bis
offensichtlich der bundesregierung
bewusst dass die kosten noch deutlich
höher liegen also wenn sie sich die
ganzen freiheitsbeschränkungen maßnahmen
anschauen wenn sie sich die auswirkungen
auch auf die gesundheit in anderen
bereichen anschauen auch die bildung auf
die psychosoziale situation von familien
von kindern dann muss man sagen dass die
verhältnismäßigkeit hier eben nicht
gewahrt ist und dass der look down
gerade jetzt wo wir den deutlichen
rückgängen incidents namen gottseidank
entschieden zu weit geht der
haben aber gefordert habe so nicht
weitergehen über 60.000 toten ist das
nicht der der maßstab den erzählt dass
wir nicht noch mehr tote haben zunächst
einmal empirisch dann müsste man schauen
wie viele dieser toten wirklich an
cholera gestorben sind darüber haben wir
bedauerlicherweise kein valides
datenmaterial was schade ist das könnte
man ja durchaus feststellen lassen das
wird aber zu wenig gemacht und schauen
sie wenn sie wenn die bundesregierung
jetzt sagt gerade die kanzlerin
wir müssen vorsichtig sein mit den
mutationen vorsicht ist in der tat eine
wichtige geschichte aber kein mensch
glaubt doch dass die beiden mutationen
die wir da jetzt im moment haben die
letzten sein werden man muss kein
biologe sein das heißt sie ein bisschen
oder sicher zu ahnen dass es weitere
geben wird wollen wir dann einen lockt
infinitum machen das muss doch
irgendwann einmal enden
und zwar auf eine vernünftige art und
weise haben wir schauen welche maßnahmen
muss man beibehalten und dabei
massenveranstaltung ich glaube da
besteht überhaupt kein zweifel wir
können jetzt nicht dass ich im stadion
vom bvb die südkurve wieder füllen oder
sowas das funktioniert nicht aber wenn
sie einen schulschließungen denken wenn
sie einen einzelhandel gallery
gaststätten denkt wohl geeignet wieder
jene maßnahmen da sind die haben ja
alles er denkt okay da kann dann ist
dort definitives unverhältnismäßig nicht
zu öffnen dann herunter punkt per
kubicki was ist unverhältnismäßig im
moment in der art wie wir mit der
pandemie umgehen ist es und ist es
verhältnismäßig die friseure auf dem
ersten platz
denen die geschäfte zu öffnen und dafür
die fitnessstudios nicht gesehen nicht
also das sind doch alles dinge die den
bürgern schwer zu erklären sind also
überall dort wo es ja die funktions
risiko ausschließen können ist eine
maßnahme unverhältnismäßig die
bayerische staatsoper beispielsweise hat
ja mit begleitung der tu münchen einen
versuch gestartet und festgestellt dass
sie 30 prozent ihrer zuschauer und
zuhörer bei deren hygiene konzept dort
unterbringen können und auch spielen
können ohne dass eine infektionsgefahr
gibt deshalb ist die schließung der
bayerischen staatsoper unverhältnismäßig
wenn man rein luft herstellen kann in
schulen oder in gastronomischen
betrieben wie bei einem dentallabor ist
die schließung unverhältnismäßig weil
von dort keine gefahr ausgeht aber noch
einmal wir debattieren so weit sei das
eine frage der politischen opportunität
alles staatliche handeln ist in
deutschland an gesetze gebunden
die haben ein eindeutiges gesetz und
dieses gesetz ist nicht beliebig also
die bundeskanzlerin kann ich sagen gibt
statt 250 spielt gar keine rolle mehr
wie mit 35 35 erreicht haben dann nehmen
wir 10
gestern kam eine studie aus israel
heraus wonach die impfung in israel dazu
geführt hat dass die todesfälle um 70
prozent gesunken sind bei den menschen
über 60 die schweren verläufe um 60
prozent gesunken sind und ich sage mal
hätten wir genauso mit dem impfen
begonnen wie großbritannien oder israel
auch noch impfstoff sind für impfen wir
hätten deutlich weniger tote deutlich
weniger schwerer verläufe die ja auch
eine kategorie sein müssen bei der
beurteilung der maßnahmen die ergriffen
worden sind wir gerne schließlich
deutschland ist der mindestens heute
gesagt lockern im lockdown weil wir
festgestellt haben der langen langer
beratung auch mit mit einer reihe von
experten dass bestimmte massnahmen
einfach nicht mehr aufrechterhalten
werden können es gibt
gerichtsentscheidung das nicht nur
friseure öffnen dürfen sondern müssen
sie gleichzeitig auch in andere
körpernahe dienstleistungen wie
nagelstudios und eine andere dinge mehr
und wer diese griff das trio terium sein
was muss das kriterium sei die zahl der
an muss ich messen ob die strategie dass
das zentrale kriterium muss sein das war
ja am anfang an auch so formuliert
worden
wer wird unser gesundheitswesen mit
schweren verläufen belastet haben wir
hohe todesraten das muss reduziert
werden wenn wie herr droste nunmal juni
letzten jahres gesagt dieses virus
mutiert zu einer infektiösen aber
trotzdem einem virus das keine schweren
verläufen verursacht also einer etwas
stärkeren grippe dann spielen die
inzidenz zahlen keine rolle mehr weil
eben keine schweren verläufen keine
todesfall zahlen dazu führen könne dass
wir damit umgehen können
frau kipping was sagen sie denn was was
ist für sie der maßstab dass sie sich
dann auch jetzt trauern in sachsen die
schulen wieder zu öffnen obwohl sie noch
eine höhere instanz zahl haben eben
nicht die 35 und nicht die 50
also sie haben eben ja schon gesagt es
ist wichtig dass man die kinder und
jugendliche nicht dass das ist so lange
dauert aber dann wäre es doch sinnvoll
dass bundeseinheitlich zu tun
na ja nochmal bildungshoheit des landes
arado jahres an das andere ist
tatsächlich dass wir nicht das 1 nein
wir sind nicht das einzige bundesland
was jetzt die kitas geöffnet hat ganz im
gegenteil werden sehr stringenten
betreuung die letzten wochen und monate
und das gleiche trifft für die
grundschulen zu wir hatten eben
keinerlei kinder in den grundschulen
bisher also insofern sind wir bei weitem
nicht das erste bundesland und wir haben
uns das erst getraut wenn ich das so
sagen darf bei dieser instanz die ich ja
schon erwähnt habe mich bei 74 also das
ist das ein und es soll ja ab nächste
woche gelten wo ich auch noch die
hoffnung habt das institut noch ein
stück weiter sinkt das andere ist das
will ich auch noch mal ausdrücklich
sagen wo kommen wir denn her und herr
kubicki hat das angedeutet auch wir
rechnen doch nicht nur eine instanz
natürlich gucken wir uns auch an wie das
gesundheitswesen überlastet oder
ausgelastet war
wenn man sich die zeit zwischen
weihnachten und neujahr in sachsen
angeschaut hat würden mittlerweile
patienten in andere bundesländer verlegt
haben weil eben das so schwierig war in
unseren krankenhäusern dass wir
tatsächlich auf hilfe angewiesen waren
dann weiß man dass wir genau abwägen was
wir tun können und was nicht
und nochmal das ist auch keine
entscheidung die hier einzelne treffen
das was ich mache ist unterschreiben das
ist richtig eine verordnung aber der weg
bis dahin da wird sehr breit getragen in
sachsen und nochmal ich war heute drei
stunden lang im parlament bei drei
verschiedenen ausschüssen und habe die
verordnung punkt für punkt miteinander
mit den abgeordneten diskutiert und
genauso mit den sechs städte sächsischen
städten und gemeinden und landkreisen so
dass die abwägung die wir getroffen
haben eine sehr gute und sehr breite ist
da ist nicht jeder einverstanden mit
jedem punkt keineswegs aber wir haben
die große abwägung getroffen und ich
will es auch noch mal so sein konzert
ich kenne das sehr gut also von dem hin
und her als wir im dezember
beziehungsweise im november so weit
waren dass wir sowohl instanzen haben da
kam immer wieder der vorwurf zu spät zu
spät zu spät jetzt machen wir es
umgekehrt und sagen jetzt können wir das
ein oder andere wagen dann heißt es zu
früh zu früh zu früh die bundeskanzlerin
hat ganz klar waren zu verzeichnen hat
ja die bundeskanzlerin hat dann ganz
klar gesagt so hätte ich gerne neben den
nach einer pflege auch nicht noch mal
erich raeder sorry ich rede ja nicht von
meinem kurs deren schritt vom kostbarer
die ihn ständig kritisieren
und das ist eben zb der fdp die
einerseits sagt viel zu viel geschlossen
auf der anderen seite viel zu viel
geöffnet das kennen wir doch jetzt über
monate und wie schnell man vergessen hat
wo wir eigentlich herkommen das erstaunt
mich immer wieder vor schönen menschen
dieses aber betrifft die haben das nicht
vergessen er frau schön
wie sehen sie diese diskussion das heißt
ja auch immer der bundestag ist so wenig
hat so wenig debattiert soll darüber ist
dass ein punkt wo sie sagen ja da hätten
wir anders und mehr alle miteinander
reden müssen und das parlament stärker
beteiligen müssen
ich finde das parlament ist sehr gut
angebunden wir sehen ja in dieser
diskussion dass die grundlage von allen
maßnahmen das infektionsschutzgesetz ist
und das hat der deutsche bundestag
beschlossen
genau mit diesen schnellen 35 und 50 und
die maßnahmen der bundesländer müssen
natürlich die bundesländer machen das
ist im fürther da dies muss so und
deshalb finde ich es ja auch gut dass
sich untereinander abgestimmt wird aber
ich würde schon noch gerne nochmal auf
das eingehen was die staatsministerin
gesagt weil das ist doch genau der punkt
wir hatten doch im november den lock
downlight gemacht und da dachten wir
naja mit maske und abstand und wenn sich
alle gut daran halten dann dann passt
das schon dann kommen wir schon gut
durch und wir haben gesehen dass es
nicht funktioniert und deshalb weiß ich
gar nicht wo die fdp den optimismus her
hat von der afg ganz zu schweigen dass
wir jetzt auf dem niveau wo wir jetzt
sind öffnen können und mit abstand und
mundschutz irgendwie hier gut
durchkommen
also dieser locker und hat doch gezeigt
danach sind die zahlen gestiegen und es
ist genau das passiert was die
staatsministerin gesagt hat alle haben
gesagt 'warum hattet ihr nicht die kraft
als politik noch länger durchzuhalten
wann hattet ihr nicht die kraft die
maßnahmen so zu machen dass wir die
zahlen tatsächlich nach unten bekommen
ich habe menschen getroffen die hatte
angst um ihr leben um ihre angehörigen
die noch nicht geimpft sind und wir
wissen ja noch das muss ich auch immer
gesagt die impfung ist dann der
hoffnungsschimmer und dann haben wir
gemerkt wir haben jetzt viel zu wenig
impfstoff also das wurde uns ja auch mal
vorher ganze dann kommt ja es wird dir
ja aber die frage stellt wie lange hast
mir ja herr kubicki sagt jetzt israel
also wenn wir die daten unserer bürger
so an pfizer verkauft hätten wie das
israel macht da hätte ich die fdp mal
hören wollen die immer für den
datenschutz ist also das sind auch
wirklich dass das ist doch nicht ich
rege mich bist ein echter schön warum
sie einen so merkwürdigen popanz
aufbauend israel verimpft
sie können sagen die fans deshalb
schneller weil sie mit weise ein
geschäft geschlossen was die europäische
union nicht gemacht hat aber die
tatsache dass sie schneller geimpft
haben als wir bedeutet eben das bei uns
mehr menschen sterben als sie hätten
sterben müssen das bedeutet dass wir
mehr schwere verläufe haben
das bedeutet dass ein doktorand länger
bleiben muss ich gucke mir das an
großbritannien hat mittlerweile mehr
menschen geimpft als die gesamte
europäische union wären sie denn auch
für den notfall zulassung gewesen
selbstverständlich sind in einer
pandemie und wir haben eine vielzahl von
problemen nicht aber den kindern und
jugendlichen sondern auch bei den
menschen die nicht mehr zur
krebsvorsorge gehen aus lauter angst bei
den menschen die um ihre existenz
bringen weil sie gar nicht wissen wie
sie ihr leben gestalten sollen
wir beide haben das große glück dass
unser geld gezahlt wird jeden monat die
müssen es darum keine gedanken
aber ich kriegen sie ja wahrscheinlich
auch briefe und mails wo leute mir
schreiben mit 160 jahren wir stehen kurz
vorm selbstmord weil wir unseren
lebenswerk zerstört sind und keine
perspektive mehr haben
darum müssen wir jetzt ein zweifel hier
auch kümmern also bauen sie keinen
falschen puck macht die sache auch nicht
öffnen auf teufel komm raus sondern wir
sagen wir haben ja die inzidenz zahlen
im gesetz festgeschrieben und daran sind
geknüpft die intensität der maßnahmen
mit denen wir grundrechtseingriffe
bedienen dürfen als sozusagen menschen
als juristen und wenn die institute
zahlen sinken dann sind sie verpflichtet
entsprechend zu reagieren sie können
nicht sagen wir haben ist die inzidenz
von 40 waren aber maßnahmen in bayern
die von den sie denn zeit von 200
gedacht waren also der 50 kilometer
ausgangssperre bleibt noch bestehen das
geht recht nicht einfach nicht und ein
letzter satz wenn der
verfassungsgerichtspräsident öffentlich
erklärt dass sie sich mehr
parlamentarische beteiligung wünscht
weise massive grundrechtseingriffe nicht
auf dem verordnungswege geschehen können
das ist das nicht unser menschsein der
kriegspräsident demonstriere deutschland
früher ihr parteikollege der mancher
öffentlich nicht aus jux und tollerei
sondern weil er sieht dass hier im
parlament eine menge vorbeigeht erneuten
schau mal nach vorne was wäre denn für
sie jetzt wenn sie sagen sie wollen
diesen lockern nicht mehr die ihnen
geeignete maßnahme um dieses virus auch
mit diesen schwierigen mutationen zu
bekämpfen
wir müssen einfach dem elementaren
vernunft prinzip folgen statt panik und
angstmacherei wenn frau schön hier sagt
die menschen haben fürchterliche angst
ja das glaube ich die ist von der
regierung auch reichlich befördert
worden
man kann damit vernünftig umgehen einmal
wir sagen ja nicht dass alle maßnahmen
falsch sind wir heiß konkret das ist ja
nun das hat die welt ausführlich
berichtet dass der wissenschaftler
angehalten wurden an der angstmacherei
auch teilzuhaben das für mein kompass
verstören ich würde gern wissen
die ist konkret machen wollen ihre
partei sei klar wird dieser locker und
so soll beendet werden was wollen sie
jetzt machen wenn sie in dieser bund
länder runde gesetzt was hätten sie denn
beschlossen also zunächst einmal lassen
natürlich sagen dass ich auch die
parlamentarische beteiligung massiv an
man würde dir geschieht nämlich immer
erst nachträglich und das ist
unangemessen sondern wir leben doch mal
ein täschchen demokratie da müssen
dementsprechend die parlamente auch
beteiligt sein das geschieht hier immer
anschließend das ist falsch
wir sagen dass die ein großteil der
maßnahmen inzwischen aufgehoben werden
kann und zwar überall da wo jene
konzepte es ermöglichen dass aufzuheben
weil die schäden die durch den lockt
dann verursacht werden immer größer
werden das heißt wir etwas gelernt haben
eine arm verdammen in toto alles normal
wo wir massenveranstaltungen haben wo im
menschen dicht auf dicht sind das geht
in der tat in dieser zeit nicht aber da
wo geeignete hygiene konzepte da sind
etwa im bereich von hotellerie
gaststätten übrigens auch schulen da
geht das man muss sich die fatalen
konsequenzen der geschichte anschauen
was man zum beispiel machen kann in
puncto schulen das halte ich für ganz
wichtig ich krieg das mit wir haben vier
kinder hier im haus kolleg glauben sie
mir ich weiß davon ein lied zu singen
was sind das heißt was das übrigens auch
für die lehrerinnen und lehrer heißt die
machen aber sie werden sich die schule
als sie werden also für eine schule
öffnen aber für hotel auf der eröffnung
ich sage aber lassen sie mich zu den
schul öffnungen was sagen lassen sich
zudem schuf und was sagen die zentrale
gefahr die wir da haben ist nicht im
unterricht selbst sondern ist der
transport zur schule und von der schule
zurück da sind die kinder eng
eingepfercht in schulbussen und da sind
dann übertragungs risiken tatsächlich da
das kann man intelligent lösen in denen
ich alle zur gleichen zeit schulbeginn
und schulende haben auch das auf der
gleichen zeit pause haben sondern da
kann man mit versetzen lösungen arbeiten
dass wir viel zu wenig gemacht ich kenne
das aussehen aus dem ok sehr sehr
eindringlichen berichten meine eigenen
kinder
da muss man einfach flexibler herangehen
das kann man
und das scheint mir eine gewisse
entschuldigung denkfaulheit bei der
regierung vorzeichen entweder wir machen
alles zu oder wir machen alles auf das
geht es ja mal irgendwann liegen im
moment eher fragen
mal nach bei frau kipping wie geht denn
sachsen damit um konkret mit solche mit
zb mit den schulhof nungen dann wie wir
garantieren sie dass das die kinder
nicht so eng zusammen sind werden jetzt
die erzieherin werden die lehrerin
geimpft ab montag wie funktioniert das
na ja die frage die muss man ganz klar
beantworten wir haben eine forderung in
der prioritäten festgelegt sind das ist
punkt nummer eins nach der verordnung
arbeiten die unter wissen wir dass die
lehrerinnen und erzieher eben noch nicht
in der ersten priorität sollte nicht auf
einer dortigen unterstütze ich das sehr
dass man das dass das unterstütze ich
sehr das eben bei der prioritäten
ordnung für lehrer und erzieher es
geändert wird das ist das eine aber die
voraussetzungen die wir dafür brauchen
ist eben auch genügend impfstoff weil
die menschen die im moment am meisten an
kurven versterben das sind eben die
älteren und genau deswegen gibt es
abzuwägen wenig eben zuerst entweder das
ist das eine das andere ist dass wir in
sachsen so arbeiten dass wir mit festen
gruppen sowie in den kitas als auch
nennt grundschulen die wir jetzt
geöffnet haben arbeiten das heißt dass
die kinder immer die gleiche gruppe
treffen in der sie so wollen die kita
gehen als auch in der grundschule also
das ist das was wir eben machen wollen
und der punkt dass man beim öpnv also
beim schülerverkehr etwas tun muss den
namen auch bei uns die landkreise schon
im herbst erkannte skype plant
landkreise die durchaus den
schülerverkehr verstärkt haben und zu
entfernen und trotzdem handelt es sich
dort um kinder
das darf man ja nicht verkennen und auch
wenn der bus halb leer oder halb voll
ist werden die kinder sich nicht alle
aber zwei bänke aufhalten sondern werden
schon miteinander in kontakt kommen und
vor allem die größeren kinder die ein
sozialleben haben auch außerhalb der
schule und deswegen ist es eben nicht so
einfach immer nur eine einrichtung zu
betrachten sondern muss auch betrachten
was alles dazu führt bevor man in dieser
einrichtung kommen wenn ich dem folgen
würde was er heute sagt das ja nirgends
irgendwo was passieren kann
ob jetzt in der gastronomie oder ob im
hotel oder im konzert oder wo auch immer
mal abgesehen von großveranstaltungen
dann bräuchte dann hätten wir keine
pandemie
das muss man ja deutlich sagen weil
viele haben sich wirklich angestrengt
die ganze zeit um hier keine konzepte zu
erarbeiten und und und aber wenn eben
auf dem weg zur gastronomie man sich
trifft oder wenn man sich vor der kita
trifft und vielleicht ein schwarz hält
was eigentlich ein ganz normales
soziales verhalten ist durch man nicht
verkennen
dann passiert es eben an diesen stellen
und deswegen kann ich nicht nur die
einrichtung selbst betrachten sondern
muss das gesamte umfeld tun und deswegen
ist er will kontakte zu beschränken
erstmal in der hohen pandemie der
richtige und zu hause zu bleiben das ist
der richtige weg auch wenn es weh tut
und hat ist trotzdem ist dann merkwürdig
dass dann zwei für die friseure jetzt
öffnen dürfen
also das sind doch alles sachen die man
nicht so ganz versteht und wenn man doch
viele haben ja hygiene konzepte
ausgearbeitet auch viele restaurants
theater museen frau schulen gibt es da
nicht nur möglichkeit wo man sagt wir
müssten da doch ein stück lockern weil
wir uns ja auch inzwischen weil wir
sehen uns ja auch inzwischen geübt nach
so vielen monaten und wir können auch
den bürgern vertrauen dass sie sich
daran halten und dann schaffen wir diese
lange strecke besser ja natürlich müssen
wir ja so schwierig weil wir sehen uns
ja nicht also nur auch für die zuschauer
es ist aber schwierig für die die
zugeschaltet sind weil die sehen uns da
nicht und deshalb ist es auch eben nicht
wie so eine runde wie früher sondern
eine ko runde
genau wie so vieles und der stadt sehen
wir uns ja auch alles danach dass wir
öffnen und dass wir auch die schritte
machen und ich bin genauso der meinung
wir brauchen eine perspektive auch die
kultur die gastronomie vor allem der
einzelhandel die müssen auch wissen auf
welcher incident kann ich mich dann
darauf einstellen dass ich wieder öffnen
kann und die haben schon die konzept und
die kann man auch noch mal nagel sondern
auch den erholungspfad aber nach all den
monaten der pandemie können wir doch
jetzt nicht bei einer inzidenz von 80 90
+ mutationen damit anfangen sondern wir
müssen doch wenigstens die geduld haben
noch die kurve weg könnte aber auch
sagen schön wir haben schadet es weniger
geschäft ja aber dann können wir gleich
noch zu kommen aber wir müssen einfach
weiter runter denn es ist ein
exponentielles wachstum mit diesem virus
kein lineares und deshalb je tiefer
unten wir sind desto leichter ist es das
ganze im griff zu halten aber trotzdem
werde ich jedes mal testen ihr gerne
auftrag das ist das richtige stichwort
ich setze ganz viel hoffnung in die
tests vor allem bei den schulen und bei
den kindergarten dort brauchen wir
wirklich ist es strategien für die
lehrer aber am besten auch für die
schülerinnen und schüler und auch für
die kinder auch schon hätte entwickeln
können vor ein paar monaten und was ist
schon gehts in die schnelltests da
gehören jetzt die konzepte werden tut
das natürlich auf dich war bo stück
stück wenn ich mir die als privatperson
hole das ist relativ
das kann man sie am besten was wir tun
ja was ist uns mehr wer hat also die
bildung der kinder und auch die sozialen
schäden die mit der schließung der
kindergärten und schulen auf dauer an
gelten was ich hier machen möchte ist
dass es eben so lange dauert das im
moment eben nicht überall schnell test
so günstig zur verfügung stehen obwohl
man das doch schon vor seit wochen hätte
machen können also ich wirklich bin
natürlich ein erkenne zunächst frau
schön aus sagt wir brauchen einen pfad
der ja das ist ja nichts anderes als die
errichtung eines stufenplans niemals
fordert ja sofort alles auf zu machen
sondern in der tat müssen wir schauen
möchten ja gut meine niemand der
vernünftig argumentieren fordert die
komplette öffnung so frei jetzt haben
die länder schleswig-holstein
niedersachsen nordrhein-westfalen
thüringen anderen möchte man ja einfach
den stufenplan ermittelt und
festgestellt bei den cds von 50
beispielsweise können wir jetzt wieder
riskieren
die kita ist vollständig zu öffnen mit
gegen hygiene konzepten und die
grundschulen wieder im präsenzunterricht
in wechselnde recht laufen zu lassen
darüber kann man diskutieren aber
jedenfalls ist das eine wirksame
maßnahmen bei einer effizienz von 40
haben wir festgelegt können wir auch
wieder mehr einzelhandel öffnen mit
hygiene konzepten also nicht alle
gleichzeitig in den laden hinein sondern
auch nur mit maske und begrenzt aber ein
solcher stufenplan gibt den leuten ja
perspektive denen haben wir nicht bei
der letzten em pk mit der
bundeskanzlerin ist zugesagt von steht
in dem papier das der bund bis zu 1000
epaper eine sprechende stufen plan
vorlegt das ist nicht geschehen und wir
wissen nicht warum das muss ja
vielleicht mal erklärt werden kann auch
einmal dass ich keine frage des
politischen willens das ist eine frage
der rechtlichen notwendigkeit auf der
grundlage unseres
infektionsschutzgesetzes wer das ändern
will muss das gesetz ändern da kann ich
einfach sagen wir setzen uns mal
zusammen mit 15 leuten und sagen wir
machen es jetzt anders das funktioniert
so nicht frau kipping warum gibt es
diesen stufenplan nicht warum wurde da
nicht wurde der nicht beschlossen ist
euer land besetzen also präsidentenrunde
selber nicht beteiligt jedoch kann
zumindest sagen dass wir in sachsen auch
an einen solchen stufenplan arbeiten
wollen wir am samstag final
verabschieden das heißt es wird dann
genau die perspektive aufgezeigt das
halte ich auch für richtig und trotzdem
haben
den hin und wieder ist ja nichts erste
mal dass wir so ein stufenplan arbeiten
wir haben ja bereits über das
ampelsystem was kann ich machen wenn ich
bis 35 instanzen habe was kann ich
machen wenn ich bis 50 incidents nach
das ist doch nichts neues wir müssen ihn
nur verändern weil sich die situation
verändert
das tun wir und wir werden ihnen dieses
mal etwas genauer ausarbeiten damit eben
die frage der gastronomie die frage der
hotellerie genauer wird beantwortet
werden kann und die leute damit rechnen
können wann sie vielleicht mit einer
öffnung rechnen können was immer wieder
dazwischen kommen wird und das können
wir nicht planen das ist einfach so wie
tatsächlich die instanzen sich
entwickeln werden wir in sachsen haben
eine lange grenze zu tschechien verner
tschechien problemen rechnen ab geht mit
instanzen von über 1000 und deswegen
muss ich doch maßnahmen anders ergreifen
in sachsen können also wenn ich zum
beispiel ich weiß wie ich bin der das
problem im moment gar nicht hat also
insofern muss doch diese unterschiedlich
auch unterschiedlichkeit auch möglich
sein wenn ich habe auch nicht damit
geplant ja und da sagen hat beobachtet
aber sachsen
wir hatten dort fall fasst diese dass
diese zero strategie wird wie hatten sie
und trotzdem sind wir so gewachsen in
den saal im november dezember und da
habe ich die gleichen vorwürfe gehört
was es hieß viel zu spät und wenn wir
jetzt etwas machen viel zu lange also
das ist einfach da man ihnen dann mache
ich vielleicht eine pressemitteilung
kümmern montag anders als bei themen die
eine entscheidung treffen da machen wir
doch mal konkret die nachfrage die lange
grenze zu tschechien wäre es sinnvoll
die grenze jetzt wirklich zu schließen
naja soviel ich weiss ist gerade in der
abstimmung dass tschechien zu einem
hochmut aktions land wenn ich es mal so
bezeichnen darf
deklariert wird das heißt es wird auch
andere regeln geben und wir für sachsen
werden dann dort ausnahmen nur
genehmigen für pendler geben zum
beispiel den bereich gesundheitsvorsorge
beziehungsweise pflege beinhalten oder
eben auch die tier versorgung auch das
an der im grenzgebiet alles andere da
wird man sehr strenge regelungen
anführen müssen das eben nur mit test
nach sachsen hereingekommen werden kann
beziehungsweise eine 14-tägige
quarantäne gefahren werden muss und das
ist ein schutz den wir brauchen weil wir
diese situation ja schon mal erlebt
haben mit unseren nachbarländern
und da geht's nicht unbedingt testen
sondern es geht auch um die bundesländer
dr -ing
ringsherum sind und insofern ist das
eine ganz wichtige maßnahme dass wir das
im blick behalten deswegen ist es nicht
nur die instanz was formal so lapidar
gesagt worden ist sommer sind viel mehr
faktoren viele feine genau das sagt ja
immer nennen wir sind eine sehr weltes
ältesten bundesland die deutschland hat
auch das erste große test vor dem start
okay absolut und jetzt ist doch wirklich
so ein absolut schwierige entscheidungen
zu treffen
ich würde gerne erneut neue erneuten
wenn sie wäre das für sie eine sinnvolle
strategie dass man sagt man schließt die
grenzen also soweit ich weiß sind die
grenzen zu tschechien und zu tirol heute
geschlossen worden jedenfalls habe ich
das eben netz gelesen als eilmeldung ich
weiß nicht ob das stimmt aber ich halte
das unter den zahlen die wir dort haben
nämlich in tschechien für für durchaus
vernünftig sie haben übrigens ihm gesagt
kompletten und ich muss das richtig
stellen ich sah er hätte wir hier für
die beendigung aller maßnahmen
ausgesprochen
das habe ich nicht getan sondern ich
habe gesagt verhältnismäßig muss es sein
und ich habe ausdrücklich beispiele
genannt wie zum beispiel
massenveranstaltungen wo man die
maßnahmen beibehalten sollte es geht
eben hier darum so viel normalität wie
möglich und so viele einschränkungen wie
zwingend notwendig zu machen also ganz
differenzierte position
es ist mitnichten so dass ich mich hier
für eine vollständige beendigung aller
maßnahmen ausgesprochen
es gibt aber einige kreise schließen
sehr klar sagen sagt wir haben
eigentlich gar keine pandemie und allen
maßnahmen müssten sofort aufgehoben
werden ich selbst residiert und sofern
es gibt es gibt es gibt in unserer
bundestagsfraktion genau so
unterschiedliche positionen wie wir sie
in anderen parteien auch finden in der
spd teilt ja auch nicht jeder die sehr
krassen position von herr lauterbach
dass es völlig normal dass da
unterschiedliche positionen sie liegt
letztlich daran dass wir alle einen
vorläufigen wissensstand haben der nähe
der nicht endgültig wissenschaftlich
validiert ist weil ich gerade okay weil
sie gerade herr lauterbach ansprechen
den haben sie auch stark kritisiert herr
kubicki sie haben gesagt wenn es nachher
lauterbach geht dann werden wir nie aus
dem loch herauskommen weil wir jedes mal
vor der situation stehen dass das virus
mutieren kann ich warne dringend vor
pannen
wird der panik gemacht aber ich habe
mich statt sagte weise gesagt mein
freund karl lauterbach bewirbt sich für
die hauptrolle in dem film apocalypse
hinterher
ich kann diese rolle verstehen er der
ewige mahner ist wir wissen und alle
biologen wissen dass wir nicht konstant
sondern dauerhaft mutieren und wenn wir
jetzt neuerdings maßnahmen begründen mit
nichtwissen über die gefährlichkeit des
virus dann kommen wir aus der situation
hier raus ist sei denn wir haben das
virus komplett besiegt also haben die
serie cupid strategie dass die nicht
umsetzbar ist leute die meinen das
einzige was ich jemals in der menschheit
gibt menschheitsgeschichte ausgerottet
werden konnte waren die pocken und das
hat 200 jahre gedauert eine zu glauben
nicht geben wir haben regelmäßig als
auch jetzt laufen neue mutationen
weltweit wir kämen aus der situation
heraus er ist ist ungewöhnlich
wir müssen mehr mit der frage
beschäftigen wie können wir infektionen
vermeiden dann ist uns die mutation des
virus völlig egal das bedeutet überall
dort wo man sich nicht anstecken kann
oder wo die maßnahmen so sind das
infektionsrisiko beherrschbar ist sind
wir nicht verpflichtet bei den sonstigen
kollateralschäden die wir haben immer
eine güterabwägung einzutreten wollen
wir jetzt die menschen weiter in ihm in
in den situationen verharren lassen dass
ihre rechte nicht wahrnehmen können
wollen wir dass die kinder weiter zu
hause bleiben müssen wollen dass die
kinder ihre kameraden nicht treffen
können wieder neuen mut schlechter geht
wollen wir dass die wirtschaft das also
nicht die wirtschaft der usa insgesamt
nicht ganz so schlecht wie das gelegt
ich gesagt aber es gibt selbstständige
gewerbetreibende gastronomen hoteliers
künstler vornehmlich daran nie gewusst
dass die künstler hier hat es für die
freien demokraten entdecken aber die
wollen ja nicht nur geld vom staat
bekommen das ist bei ihnen gar nicht
ankommt sie wollen auch auftreten vor
publikum das ja sozusagen ihre ihr
lebensinhalt solo selbstständige
fitnessstudiobetreiber die leute die
fitness machen wollen haben menschen
können jetzt nicht in die fitnessstudios
also all die menschen haben ja auch
massive beeinträchtigungen und die
können wir nicht dauernd in diesem
zustand halten mit der erklärung wir
wissen nicht ob da noch ein virus kommt
was mutiert ist wir wissen nicht die
gefährliche mutation ist man muss immer
eine güterabwägung so ist diese nach und
man muss und es gibt ja auch viel kritik
von wirtschaftsverbänden frau schulen
das soll für die hilfe gar nicht
ankommen es gibt kritik von der spd an
ihrem wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
dass das alles zu spät ist dass das
nicht richtig oder raschelt der im
landtag von neun cdu politiker im
landtag von nordrhein-westfalen erklärt
seit
november kriegt die bundesregierung
nichts auf die kette das fand ich
bemerkenswert die cdu-vorsitzende
erklärt in berlin funktioniert nichts
was sagen sie dazu forschen
naja wir alle hätten uns gewünscht dass
das schneller geht jetzt können wir alle
mit dem finger aufeinander zeigen können
sagen herr scholz wollte unbedingt dass
wir da so viele bedingungen einführen
das hat es kompliziert gemacht deshalb
hat es so lange gedauert
am ende ist es wichtig dass die hilfe
hilfen seit gestern beantragt werden
können
das hat uns auch zu lange gedauert dass
wir stehen auch jeden tag im gespräch
mit den einzelhändlern und da es
wirklich panik da ist verzweiflung und
deshalb muss der staat alles dafür tun
dass die hilfen schnell ankommen wir
können ja froh sein dass wir die hilfen
überhaupt zur verfügung stellen können
wenn man sich mal international anschaut
dann sind wir ja das land was wirklich
auch noch am besten hilft von vielen
dass sie die vielen ländern ganz anders
aus aber weil wir es können muss es dann
eben auch schnell umgesetzt werden man
könnte aber auch sagen man ist etwas und
öffnet etwas mehr zum beispiel
gastronomie zum beispiel ein slider
bräuche soll die hilfe nicht wenn die
künftige konzepte haben ja aber all den
unternehmen hilft es auch nichts wenn
wir dann vier wochen später wieder zu
machen das ist es ja eröffnungsfahrt
muss eben auch nachhaltig sein und wenn
wir über verschiedene öffnungsrate reden
ich kenne allein drei von der fdp also
der stellvertretende ministerpräsident
in nrw hat einen die fdp selbst hat
einen der eine halb fünf der andere
glaube ich sieben punkte und sie sind
teil der regierung in schleswig holstein
die wirklich einen sehr guten plan
vorgelegt haben also da muss man sich
eben auch mal auf einige einem plan
einigen und deshalb fand ich es auch
bemerkenswert dass herr kubicki eben
gesagt hatte 840 öffnen wir dann den
einzelhandel also für mich klang das
immer anders und deshalb gehört da auch
in der opposition ein bisschen wahrheit
dazu was will man denn jetzt eigentlich
und dann kann man sich sicher auch auch
auf etwas einigen
denn auch jeder dieser also außer acht
dies jetzt natürlich auch irgendwo im
land in einer landesregierung und hatte
auch eine eigene verantwortung der frau
kipping wie sehen sie das wenn sie das
hier in berlin beobachten auch wie sich
so ein bisschen cdu und spd da doch ein
bisschen kabeln und dann
sich gegenseitig auch dinge da vorwerfen
sieht man da an einem strang in ihre
meinung oder ist das auch schon so geht
das in diesem wahljahr auch schon in
eine richtung wo es auch darum geht wer
sich da am besten profilieren kann
naja sie persönlich gesagt muss man
sagen dass die fragen die die spd
gestellt hat gerade wenn es um das thema
impfen ging oder ähnliches sind doch
richtig aber wichtig ist mir dabei dass
man diese fragen beantworteten dass man
nach vorne schaut und sagt wie geht es
jetzt weiter
also ich halte auch nicht so sehr viel
davon wenn wir jetzt mit dem finger auf
den anderen zeigen und gucken was dir
alles gemacht hat das betrifft übrigens
auch die wirtschaftshilfen
die unternehmen brauchen diese
wirtschaftshilfe dringend rascheln hat
gesagt welche schwierigkeit damit
verbunden ist das muss jetzt erfolgen
die menschen sind verzweifelt die diese
hilfe brauchen und das ist so ein weg
den müssen wir doch gemeinsam gehen da
geht es darum dass man dem anderen etwas
vorwirft sondern dass man lösungen
findet also zumindest sind wir
lösungsorientiert wenn sie auf der
landesebene geht und ich will noch ein
wurzel haben leuten sorgen weil er sagt
naja wenn der afg jemanden andere
meinung hat das konnte in allen parteien
vorn ich kann nur sagen für sachsen dass
ich die fdp da ziemlich einig ist einig
gewesen ist schon im frühjahr letzten
jahres wo sie am liebsten den notstand
ausgerufen hat wo wir instanzen hatten
die sind mit den heutigen überhaupt
nicht zu vergleichen und gleichzeitig
heute sagt alles öffnen obwohl wir immer
noch so nicht wäre zeit gerade im
dezember/januar hinter uns haben
und das ist sehr einheitlich dort
gewesen bis hin zu masken pflicht wo
immer wieder gesagt worden ist die
braucht ja keiner die wird hinterfragt
ist überhaupt sinnvoll dies sogar
schädlich all diese dinge da habe ich
keine unterschiedlichen töne gehört also
insofern zu sagen das war nur der einer
der da irgendwo von der seite geschossen
hat das nehme ich anders war
aber ich glaube für die menschen im land
ist wirklich wichtig so ich hab so was
hatten die flüge erkennen und da bin ich
völlig dabei und insofern insofern
möchte ich wirklich noch mal betonen
dass es wichtig wird dass wir diese
perspektive pläne verabschieden als
bundesländer und dass wir auch die
perspektive aufzeigen die bundesweit
geregelt werden können das ist eine ganz
wichtige maßgabe die die menschen jetzt
er das wird dann auch mal zeit in ganz
kurz am meisten weil sie es gab ja
durchaus kritik weil sie eben gerade
ihre partei kritisiert haben die von
einer corona diktatur gesprochen habe
also sie sind da schon oft anderer
meinung als viele in ihrer partei
ich habe den begriff der diktatur für
unangemessen verhalten tue ich auch
heute noch
aber schauen sie mal maßgeblich jetzt
wie gesagt wir hätten das durchaus
einheitlich gesehen herr sparen zum
beispiel als bundesgesundheitsminister
hat zu machen klingt sehr
unterschiedliche positionen bei äußerte
hat im frühjahr letzten jahres gesagt
design völlig unnötig weil auch gar
keine verfügbar waren und wenig später
war dann massiver vertrete keine masken
pflicht lassen wir noch ein paar diese
partei plänkeleien mal aus und
konzentrieren uns auf die frage was ist
vernünftig und was nicht und dann muss
man sagen dass einiges in der
bundesregierung das muss auch frauchen
kontrollieren mit verlaub dass das zu
spät kommt wenn sie die hilfen
ansprechende sagen wie finanziere ich
glaube da sind sich alle einig hätte ich
sagen dass das haben einfach zu spät und
das glaube ich alles im versagen der
europäischen union unter frau von der
leyen es ist eben auch evident und da
muss man ran und wir sind sind ja hier
in dieser runde um zu schauen welche
maßnahmen sind vernünftig welche nicht
und ich glaube da brauchen wir uns somit
den wechselseitigen vorwürfen kommen wir
da nicht weiter aufgeht denn ich habe
auch gar nicht beteiligen ist sondern er
will schauen dass wir vernünftige
lösungen finden herr kubicki wenn aldi
manche biologen waren vor einer dritten
welle die virologen melanie bringt man
die sagt wir haben das rennen gegen die
mutation schon längst verloren das war
ja und wie der worst case dass wir uns
noch auf ein ganzes jahr einstellen
müssen in dem es immer so weitergeht
sind wir da richtig gewappnet ist das
dann panikmache ich freue mich immer
wieder dass melanie brinkmann alles ganz
genau weiß bisher wissen wir gar nicht
welche auswirkungen das britische virus
tatsächlich hat wie großbritannien
können wir sehen dass wir den deutliche
maßnahmen die instanz sein
obwohl die komplett mit dem britischen
wie der würfel tante verseucht sind
der dramatischen roten sondern auch
welche wissenschaftliche expertise bauen
sieht denn ihr zunächst bilbao ich auf
die objektiven zahlen und nicht auf
modellrechnungen die ja nicht ihr nicht
wir beinhalten können wie eine pfändung
bei menschen stattfindet ich habe das
bei einem und die modellierer des rk ii
mal gesagt der gesagt hat müssen die
kontakte begrenzt da hab ich gesagt wenn
wir uns alle den abc schutzanzügen
treffen würden hätten wir überall
kontakte ohne ende aber keine
infektionen weil ich gar nicht
übertragen werden kann ja das bezeichnet
das ein bisschen diese modelle können
sendungen der menschen die erfassten es
macht einen unterschied ob man sich
trifft ohne maske oder jeweils mit sp2
maske und jetzt sage ich mal wir gucken
uns die objektiven daten an die gucken
uns die fallzahlen an die gemessene
werden die gucken
die belegungszahlen unseren
krankenhäusern die gucken muss die
todesfälle an und daran rausschauen
da haben wir uns hier können
lockerungsmaßnahmen nur vornehmen
diese zahlen tatsächlich runtergehen
insgesamt runtergehen und deshalb
brauchen wir in ansehung dieser zahl mit
einem lila regierungs faktor brauchen
wir einen stufenplan in der syrien bis
heute ablehnen wir brauchen einen
stufenplan
und ich wäre froh die bundesregierung
würde mal ihre pflicht erfüllen kann es
ja zugesagt als solche stufen zahlen
planst du zu entwickeln wann bei welchen
instituts und hole den ernährungsplan
passiert sollten sollten schulen
geöffnet werden gastronomische betriebe
große oder klar
gehen sie damit wäre das ist das was sie
sagen ja weil das ist ja keine zeit
eigentlich für parteipolitisches
gekämmten auch in einem wahlkampf ja
nicht dass man sagt wir müssen
konstruktiv nach vorne gehen ist das
nicht ein guter vorschlag der fdp dem
sie unterstützen können naja wenn ich
sehe was heute in nrw passiert ist wo
man die beschlüsse von gestern der 16
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin die wirklich nicht sehr
weit tiefgehend waren und sehr
detailreich schon heute anfängt in der
nrw regierung zu sagen daran wollen wir
uns dich halten dann frage ich mich was
passieren würde wenn die bundesregierung
einen stufenplan den könnte jedoch
bereit in dem im parlament diskutieren
und verabschieden
ja das hat frau göring-eckardt heute
auch im bundestag vorgeschlagen
bei allen erfahrungen die ich habe in
anderen bereichen ist es in der regel
der baden württembergische
ministerpräsident kretschmann der der
erste ist der sagt was der bund
vorschlägt dass daran halte ich mich
nicht ich gehe meinen eigenen weg aber
wenig vertrauen in die ems ins parlament
und auch in die so zusammen man jetzt in
dieser besonderen ausnahmesituation der
pandemie müsste man doch vielleicht auf
neueren oder entscheiden also ich würde
mir wünschen dass sich die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin auf einen stufenplan
einigen das wünschen wir uns auch
glocken und sonst okay dann sind sie
sich da schon mal einig am dritten märz
gibt's die erneute bund länder runde
das ist auch in einer sitzungswoche
erwarten sie ja kubicki dass die debatte
dann vor dem treffen mal stattfindet
doch mal bisher in erfahrung nicht ist
mein geburtstag manchmal zu sagen wenn
wir können etwas tun und das bringt
hoffnung für mich das dass man
tatsächlich hoffnung ich glaube dass der
druck der länder auf die bundes auf
denen das bundeskanzleramt so stark sein
wird das tatsächlich von dort einstufung
platz zu erwarten ist mit denen die
menschen eine perspektive bekommen hier
leben wie der planbar zu machen darauf
kommt zu hören okay das hoffen wir alle
dass wir eine perspektive haben planen
können und auch wieder schöne dinge tun
können vielen dank frau kipping vielen
dank herr morgen herr kubicki und
frauchen dann ein schönes ding wäre ja
auch karneval zu feiern das macht man ja
hätte man heute sonst im rheinland getan